bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches la 51e
de ses caches et je suis toujours là
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler d'europe
les pays qui sont repartis ou soi-disant
reparti et puis les autres
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches a
renoué au à cette semaine consacrée à
l'union européenne sommes nous dans une
europe à deux vitesses le clivage entre
le nord et le sud de l'union européenne
menace-t-il son unité ce sont les
questions que nous allons aborder dans
cet épisode de ses caches avec vous
olivier allard olivier on va commencer
par jeter un coup d'oeil à la dette des
états avec ces chiffres d'eurostat
publiée en avril dernier on va commencer
par le nord en 2018 la dette publique de
l'allemagne s'élevait à hauteur de 79 %
de son pib
celle de la suède à 38 8% du pib 34 1%
pour le danemark 64 8% pour l'irlande et
pis pour le sud l'espagne est endetté à
hauteur de 97,1 % du pib l'italie 132,2
le portugal 121,5 121 5 % par dont la
france
elle est endettée à hauteur de 98 4% et
puis la grèce bien sûr et bat tous les
records avec 181 % du pib olivier quand
on regarde ces chiffres
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
il ya une fracture mais ya toujours eu
une fracture entre le le nord et le sud
ou plutôt entre l'allemagne et ses
satellites et le reste de l'europe
je vous rappelle que on a fait
l'équivalent d'un aux marques qui
s'appelle l'euro et qui évidemment
avantage les allemands et des avantages
tout le reste donc
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui sont qui ont été
mal gérées dont la france d'ailleurs
mais tous tous les pays du sud
vous savez qu'on appelle les pays du
club med qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
sur endetté mal géré et serra et puis
vous avez l'allemagne mais l'allemagne
ceci dit elle n'est pas ce que ce
qu'elle semble être cette c'est aussi un
pays qui vieillit qui qui a des
problèmes parce que c'est un espèce de
mono modèle que à l'exportation et que l
exportation des voitures et puis tout ce
qui entoure les voitures donc c'est pas
c'est pas forcément le modèle économique
qui
qui va réussir dans les années à venir
il a déjà surperformé les autres mais ça
n'est pas non plus la panacée il que
l'allemagne a toujours été la locomotive
pourtant au départ il ya quand même un
trio de tête avec la france et au
royaume uni
vous savez le trio de tête de la france
ça fait longtemps qu'elle latinité donc
et le royaume uni n'est plus dans
l'europe jusque jusqu'à très récemment
mais là il ne l'est plus donc coeur
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas qui est la
locomotive de l'europe en tout cas ne
croyez pas que ce soit la france et est
la vraie question aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si comme le fmi l'a dit a dit que
la grèce était sorti d'affaires ce qui
évidemment archi peau mais on a parlé de
deux sorties d'affaires aussi pour
l'espagne pour le portugal avec les
baisse du chômage etc
or tout ça c'est en trompe l'oeil c'est
faux alors justement va regarder plus en
détaillant les différents économique
entre le nord et le sud avec le tiroir
cage d'antoine d'assas
il est coutume de parler de deux europes
en différenciant la vieille europe des
pays fondateurs à l'ouest de la nouvelle
europe des entrants plus récents à l'est
mais aujourd'hui on pourrait également
faire la différence entre pays du sud et
pays du nord au sud tous les pays ont
une dette énorme
en 2010 8 181 % du pib en grèce 132 % en
italie 100 % pour la france
oui on met la france dans les pays du
sud alors qu'au nord mise à part la
belgique
d autres ont une dette en trombe vite
vers une 4% pour l'estonie et 73 5% pour
l'autriche
les déficits publics sont aussi bien
plus important pour les pays du sud
dépassant la plupart du temps les 2% a
contrario du nord où on trouve même des
excédents budgétaires comme en allemagne
ou aux pays bas les pays du nord sont en
fait plus libres économiquement et la
rigueur budgétaire y est plus élevé dans
l'index of economic freedom qui classe
les pays selon leur liberté économique
irlandais 6e le danemark 14 yens la
suède 19e quand l'espagne et 57e la
france 71e ou l'adresse 106e de quoi
rabattre en tout cas les cartes des pays
forts de l'europe entre le breakbeat et
l'économie vacillante de la france on
est loin du trio fort france royaume uni
allemagne
cette fracture nord sud pourrait
déboucher sur une europe du nord où les
pays font du commerce entrevoir
peut-être
nouvelle zone monétaire le projet a déjà
été évoqué et en face une europe du sud
à la ramasse économiquement
olivier est ce que cette scission entre
les deux zones pourraient encore
s'aggraver alors elle pourrait
s'aggraver mais surtout il faut faire
attention parce que l'italie était en
excédent primaire c'est à dire avant de
payer les intérêts de la dette l'italie
était en excédent primaire donc en fait
beaucoup plus vertueuse par exemple que
la france donc il faut il faut moduler
un peu les choses là la seule chose
qu'on peut dire sur sur le les pays du
sud
c'est que contrairement à ce que essaie
de nous nous vendre le fmi notamment
mais d'autres d'autres bureaux d'études
ils sont absolument pas reparti c'est à
dire qu'on vous parle de la baisse du
chômage au portugal ou en espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
dans ces pays
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes des jeunes diplômés etc qui
sont partis donc évidemment ça vous fait
baisser le taux de chômage mais c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle si vous voulez
donc
c'est sûr sur la population du portugal
imaginez quand même que c'est plus de 10
% qui sont partis donc c'est pas rien
donc vous avez vous avez des pays qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas rester dans
l'euro parce que c'est une aberration
vous l'a dit des dizaines de fois
c'est une aberration d'essayer de
maintenir cette monnaie qui est à
d'autres marques pour des économies
comme le portugal ou comme la grèce et
ont continué de parler de l'union
européenne cette semaine nous recevons
marc touati économiste et président du
cab et du cabinet d'analysés économiques
à ces défis bonjour marc touati
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors une res une réaction à
ce que vous avez entendu en première
partie est ce que selon vous aussi on
peut parler de fracture entre le nord et
le sud de l'autre enfin le gros problème
c'est qu'effectivement on a des pays qui
vaut mieux qu'ils ont fait des réformes
contrairement d'ailleurs à france c'est
vrai olivier l'a bien dit la france est
l'un des rares pays qui commence
seulement jouer à réformer son pays tire
ou dix réformes se bat pour la réforme
et pour moderniser l'économie
on l'a vu le dernier emprunt plus
gestionnaire est le système des
retraites par exemple aujourd'hui tous
les pays européens ont modernisé la
semaine des retraites
y a qu'en france qu'on reste comme
s'arquebouter parce que évidemment on ne
sait pas la présenter cette réforme des
retraites
on reste le pays où finalement on parle
plutôt à la retraite donc c'est
formidable simplement est ce qu'on va
pouvoir continuer de le faire et comment
va-t-on financer alors que des pays
comme évidemment l'italie l'espagne le
portugal on fait ces réformes
on ne sait pas on pense qu'à que
l'allemagne il faut dire que beaucoup de
pays qu'on appelle du sud effectivement
ont quand même près former leurs
économies le gros problème c'est que on
adp qui ont redémarré un petit peu on en
reparlera réparé par exemple l'espagne
ou le portugal
pour des raisons notamment fiscales le
portugal ça je pensais trop bien que le
portugal fait un dumping fiscal
incroyable il est en train de changer
aujourd'hui mais savoir que il appelle
entre tous en gros tous les
ressortissants de l'union européenne à
venir chez eux et à ne pas payer
d'impôts pendant dix ans s'ils
reviennent de l'étranger donc évidemment
ça attire beaucoup de retraités français
par exemple on venir ils sont en train
de revenir parce qu'ils se rendent
compte que ça leur coûte trop cher les
deux parties n'ont justement fait
l'objet du bien certains sont partis par
contre vous avez encore deux grands pays
malheureusement qui souffrent énormément
vous avez l'italie et la glace pour une
raison simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
vous êtes un petit calcul très simple
pour garder ou et le pib actuellement le
dire le niveau de richesse hors
inflation
par rapport au niveau qu'on avait en
2008 y avant la crise on en imagine par
amp la france et les 10% au-dessus c'est
pas beaucoup 10 % parce que ça fait 12
ans 10 % de croissance en 12 ans avait 0
8% par an donc c'est pas grand chose
vous avez l'irlande ils sont à 50 % de
hausse
bonds est par contre dans les pays du
sud ça va mieux effectivement l'espagne
au portugal mais vous avez deux pays de
la zone euro et donc et puis du sud qui
n'ont pas encore retrouvé leur niveau de
richesse d'avant la crise vous avez la
grèce ces 23 % en deçà donc c'est pour
montrer l'ampleur des dégâts
effectivement qui en grèce et aussi
l'italie âmes italien où ils sont encore
peu près 3 5 % en deçà du niveau de 2008
donc ce à dire que pour ces pays là
rendez vous compte 2800 du samu il ya
douze ans c'est qu'on a eu 12 ans pour
rien il ya 12 ans deux de marasme
finalement alors ça remonte un petit peu
mais quand même on n'a pas réussi à
sortir de la crise malgré tout les aides
qu'on a pu avoir au niveau de la zone
euro parce que c'est là qu'olivier
l'euro est peut-être trop fort dans
certains pays pour certains pays
notamment la grèce par contre tous ces
pays là aujourd'hui
il bénéficie d'une incroyable qui
effectivement est taux d'intérêt à long
terme très bas
sk plutôt que par 2 pas être fracturé on
peut parler d' europe à deux vitesses en
fait oui donc environ on a effectivement
cette image d'une europe du nord entre
guillemets qui s'est réformée c'est vrai
alors évidemment emmenés par l'allemagne
les pays bas la belgique le tas mais qui
souffre quand même
ouais dire que globalement c'est pas non
plus l'euphorie mais néanmoins à vos
river l'année dernière les chiffres de
croissance l'allemagne va faire
seulement à peu près 0 5% en croissance
aussi ce peut être la france on est au
tour d un pareil pour des migrants et
cèdent leur exemple voilà suède et fo
s'est passé pas la zone euro l'ont
globalement elle a un modèle qui est
particulièrement à part et puis c'est
pas comparable ça reste effectivement
des petits pays avec comme les traits
particuliers mais même eux par exemple
la suède ou le danemark ou la finlande
qui étaient des pays qui effectivement
avait une dépense publique énorme sont
revenus sur ce modèle commence à réduire
la dépense plus que si bien
qu'aujourd'hui le numéro un européen des
dépenses publiques c'est qui c'est la
france et donc si vous serez quand on a
cette image où globalement audibet les
pays du sud sont les mauvais élèves
moi je trouve qu'on veut c'est aller un
peu vite ont beaucoup de pays ont fait
des réformes là c'est pas encore le
parfait mais comparativement à nous on
paye terre de la dette publique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on a cette
dette publique grecque qui est
dramatique mais là des piques française
là on a vu les chutes de 2018 à l'amont
les chiffres de 2019 et 2020 la france
est à 100% son pib jusque là mais plus
que ça mais le drame c'est quoi ces cas
la rigueur si votre dette génère une
croissance forte
bon on peut dire au diable l'avarice
mais le drame c'est que dans tous ces
pays là et notamment chez nous en france
la dette publique a augmenté mais n'a
pas généré de croissance est forte
oui donc c'est ça qui est extrêmement
douloureux c'est que on s'endette on à
la planche à billets on a des moyens
exceptionnels pour avoir une croissance
et un pour cent un peu plus
effectivement en espagne en effet de
rattrapage ou au portugal pour des
raisons fiscales
mais ce n'est pas génial c'est au lycée
peut en plus se fasse et ces deux là je
dirais c'est de la fausse croissance on
est on est de toute façon dans tous ces
pays là avec une démographie qui est au
tapis
on est sur des dvd zone 2 1,30 à peu
près quand il faut 2 10 pour juste pour
remplacer donc on est très très loin et
ça au portugal ça en espagne ça en
allemagne évidemment en italie aussi et
donc dans tous ces pays là vous avez un
impact démographique un vieillissement
de la population et surtout un ratio de
dépendance qui est aujourd'hui même au
portugal à a1
c'est à dire que vous avez indépendant
pour un actif donc de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive
vous savez que ça ne passe pas alors
aujourd'hui vous voyez le résultat vous
voyez le portugal qui est en train
d'essayer de revenir sur ses avantages
d'impôts mais ça va empirer forcément
parce que aujourd'hui n'ont rien réglé
finalement ils sont passés d'une
économie qui était une économie de
d'export agricole et de 2,2 d'industrie
à une économie de tertiaire 75% est on
aujourd'hui tout est basé sur le fait
qu'ils attirent quelques retraités
riches retraités
mais une fois que vous ne m'avez plus
cet avantage fiscal pourquoi voulez-vous
aller au portugal et à ce moment là vous
allez retombées en termes de croissance
vous n'avez rien réglé au niveau de la
dette
vous êtes toujours à 130% à peu près sur
le le le niveau de dette et donc vous ne
passez plus et la grèce a été un exemple
quand j'entends quand on quand on a
entendu madame lagarde qui depuis le
départ nous explique que la gay la grèce
est sauvée mais c'est une c'est une
vaste plaisanterie aujourd'hui va donc
on a on a une un pays qui est mourant la
grèce donc le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à camoufler sa
part d injection monétaire c'est-à-dire
la banque centrale européenne maintient
les taux à zéro du rendez vous compte
que aujourd'hui le vin en grec et en
dessous du 10 ans américain
c'est à dire qu'on prête plus facilement
à la grèce avec des taux plus bas qu'on
ne prête aux états unis faille à un
moment où il faut pas réfléchir à la
question inverse on va marquer une
courte pause en rien dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez on parle de l'union européenne
avec marc touati économiste et président
du cabinet d'analysés économiques à ces
défis marc touati juste avant la pub on
l'a vu dans le tiroir cachant les pays
du nord sont classées comme étant
économiquement plus libre qu'est ce qui
fait que le libéralisme et la rigueur
budgétaire comme on l'a vu dans le
tiroir ne ne fonctionnent pas aussi sûr
qu incarne je suis pas sûr de ce
classement
ja libéral ça veut rien dire quand vous
avez des pays qui ont 50 % ou 50 2 % de
dépenses publiques par rapport à leur
pib
si tu n es pas beaucoup de pays du nord
c'est pas très libérale tout ça donc à
la france j'en parle même pas on est 1
56%
non je pense qu'aujourd'hui le vrai
problème et olivier l'a bien l'a bien
montré un sait qu'on a une sorte de déni
de réalité il ya que fait tout est
faussé par le fait qu'on a une anomalie
économique et financière qui est que
malgré que la dette publique augmente
les taux d'intérêt baissent donc le cas
de la grèce symptomatique ce qui
effectivement parce que la crise grecque
ainsi vous souvenez ans 2010 2012 à
l'époque la dette grecque étaient prêts
à 170% du pib
bon et tout me dire là c'est horrible
tout va s'effondrer et c est donc
l'europe et enfin la zone euro est
intervenu on a annulé de la dette
grecque etc
à l'époque le taux d'intérêt à dix ans
de la dette grecque était à 35%
c'est une sanction des marchés bon les
européens ont la dette grecque est
retombé à 140
hélas aujourd'hui on l'a vu quelles
heures elle est remontée à 180 pour cent
du pib
sauf que les taux d'intérêt sont pas à
35 qui sont pas vains et sont pas 10 ils
sont à 1%
l'intérêt à 10 ans non on marche sur la
tête ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils fassent
piquer l'argent c'est ce que c'est qu'un
taux d'intérêt c'est le sait le coût de
votre risque
et quand c'est votre assurance c'est le
coût de votre risque donc il est évident
que quand vous payez 35%
c'est que vous savez que vous avez
énormément de chance de ne jamais revoir
votre art exactement donc
et le fait est que aujourd'hui vous avez
le même même bien pire
la même chance de ne pas revoir votre
argent mais vous savez quoi
vous savez que vous avez la banque
centrale qui de toute façon viendra à
votre secours
enfin vous pensez ça que la banque
centrale viendra à votre secours et à ce
moment là vous avez des taux d'intérêt
qui ne correspondent absolument pas au
coût du risque puisque
vous êtes je vous dis en dessous d'eux
des taux d'intérêt américains et a
priori vous prenez quand même plus de
risques à prêter à la grèce à prêter aux
états unis bon mais les marchés ont
décidé que de toute façon comme monsieur
draghi madame lagarde fera whatever it
takes pour pour pour intervenir et que
donc il n'y aura pas de faillite de la
grèce et qu' il n'y aura pas de haircut
sur la gagne alors c'est un jeu
dangereux c'est parce que forte de
cocaïne qu'elle allait se terminèrent de
paradis artificiels où finalement on ne
regarde plus la réalité en face
dire que c'est ça qui est dramatique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne reconnaît pas
cette réalité lors du non mais c'est pas
grave
l'abbé ce sera avec sa wii mais quand
même si on ne rembourse pas votre dette
bien vous allez perdre donc c'est qu'on
oublie ce que même si la dette ne coûte
pas cher elle est là et vous qu'un à
rembourser donc si on n'est pas
remboursé on a une perte sèche sans
parler du fait que si les taux remontent
même un petit peu
ben on allait les cours des obligations
qui baisse on a effectivement des pertes
donc c'est ça qui est très dangereux si
vous voulez c'est que aujourd'hui
effectivement les pays du sud sont
tenues avec 7,7 un peu artificiel mais
jusqu'à quand cette fin à cette fuite en
avant parce que je donne donné par les
deux minutes tout à l'heure quand tu es
2008 2009
on a pu relancer la machine pourquoi
parce qu'on avait les moyens de le faire
on a baissé de l'intérieur a fait de la
relance budgétaire que c'était à retirer
sa planche à billets aujourd'hui on n'a
plus de moyens on les a déjà utilisé
donc qu'on voulait faire pour baisser
les tourner jazz héros vous allez ou en
négatif on servira pas à grand-chose
dette publique elle déjà plus de 100 %
comment va oui c'est ça qui m'inquiète
c'est c'est comment on fait lorsque la
nouvelle crise avec qui on arrive donc
ce que cet aveuglement collectif alors
c'est que bon quand on me dit on à face
à ça pour revenir à l équilibre alors
malheureusement je pense que c'est ça
qui est dramatique c'est qu'on va devoir
passer par le clash ce que l'on en fait
on a complètement perdu
l'échelle des valeurs on ne sait plus ce
que ça vaut quand on a une dette
publique grecque à 180% qui ramène 1%
oui ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le couple
rendement risque c'est la règle de base
de l'économie sous les égouts quand le
rendement augmente le risque augmente
oui dont on inverse qu on a un risque
élevé et le rendement baisse donc on a
c'est pire que les subprimes ou est-ce
que cette prime on avait un risque élevé
il y avait un rendement élevé là il ya
non seulement il fera pas de miroir et
un risque élevé mais ya pas de rang
bon on est sûr de perdre ses moyens il
faut passer par un cache c'est à dire
c'est à dire que je pense que
globalement un moment il va falloir
faire mettre les pendules à l'heure
remettre les pendules à zéro entre
guillemets et donc il y aura évidemment
certainement je dirais un krach boursier
et obligataire et c'est triste parce que
à la fin qui va payer
c'est un malheureusement les populations
tout ça parce qu'on a cette fuite en
avant et c'est là où la banque centrale
ne joue pas son rôle
c'est à dire qu'elles devraient au
contraire calmer le jeu arrêté de
d'alimenter d'alimenter cette bulle mais
néanmoins geste est moins sûr sur les
pays du sud il faut quand même pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain
et quand même eu notamment par l'italie
du nord et comme beaucoup d'entreprises
qui ont su investir qui ont su innover
en espagne c'est un petit peu moins au
portugal ça commence à arriver
aujourd'hui
donc ça qui est dommage c'est que en
fait c'était 7,7 cette aide artificielle
exempt d'or donc si on avait une
sanction avec des intérêts plus dur
labeur faut arrêter de faire des bêtises
comme on dit maintenant on peut
continuer comme ça éternellement
c'est ça qui est dangereux c'est qu'on
revient dans cette ce que j'appelle
cette cocaïne quoi c'est à dire c'est ce
paradis artificiels donc on ne prend pas
les bonnes mesures et olivier la
solution passera passera par un clash
selon vous oui mais les marchés sont
aujourd'hui persuadés que
le le pouvoir des banques centrales est
illimité c'est à dire que il joue en se
disant de toute façon il n'y a pas de
limites physiques a l'impression
monétaire ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui si
je vous dis la bce à 4700 milliards à
son bilan
demain elle en a huit mille est-ce que
ça va vous faire ce que ça vient monde
il a fait d'épilepsie je crois pas donc
et à personne est en fait le marché joue
là dessus en disant mais de toute façon
il n'y a pas de limite donc quoi qu'il
arrive et on le voit d'ailleurs au
moment du cornaro virus qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et bien tout de suite
la banque centrale chinoise a mis 300
milliards sur la table rien 308 et elle
va mettre 1000 milliards au total
et je pense que s'il y avait eu besoin
de deux mille milliards y aurait eu deux
me mignard
les à la chine elle alors quelle est la
chanson billie jean elle les achète à
une dette gigantesque mais oui générale
les amis mais vous aurez la même le même
phénomène aux états unis vous aurez le
même phénomène en europe
c'est à dire que ce cette alerte
sanitaire va servir de prétexte à
délivrer et a continué à délivrer c'est
à dire qu'on va vous dire oui mais
finalement on s'était dit qu'on allait
peut-être arrêter baisser les taux pions
avec ce qui s'est passé on est obligé de
les baisser
et puis on est obligé de faire un qu eux
et on est obligé de grossir le cul eux
parce que il n'ya pas de limite et c'est
là que ça fait un certain temps que je
le dis c'est de la drogue c'est à dire
vous n'en sortez pas il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible
vous êtes obligé à chaque fois
d'augmenter la dose parce que sinon le
système s'écroule et donc les marchés
jouent la thur en se disant de toute
façon on est assurés parce qu'on
augmentera la dose à chaque fois parce
qu'on ne peut pas louer nous laisser
tomber
c'est un risque parce que si à un moment
justement les banques centrales perdre
la main et n'arrivent pas à contrecarrer
la baisse ça risque d'être rigolo et
oreillers je précise juste que pour le
spectateur c'est quantitative easing
pardon max et si on parle beaucoup à des
pays du nord des pays du sud un mot les
pays de l'est comme par exemple la
roumanie et la bulgarie
alors justement ça c'est ce que c'est un
point très important qui va sinon oui
tout à fait c'est un point très
important pour expliquer justement
pourquoi les pays du sud se sont un
petit peu effondré
ça date de quand cela est effectivement
de 2007 2010 au moment où effectivement
on a eu les nouveaux entrants il ya les
nouveaux pays effectivement je dirais
donc le d'europe de l'est qui sont
arrivés dans l'union européenne
je sais comment ça se passe en fait
l'union européenne tout le monde cotise
en fonction de son sa richesse et après
on redistribue on donne des aides par
exemple l'espagne jusqu'en 2007 l
accaparer à elle seule près 17 % de
toutes les aides communautaires de
l'union européenne on s'était même
beaucoup arrivent l'élargissement donc
on a dix nouveaux pays des rillettes
demi part supplémentaire et le pib
n'augmentant pas beaucoup parce que ces
dix pays qui sont relativement pauvres
et donc la victime en la part de
l'espagne tombe à 4 %
donc c'est le nouveau pays et puis donc
de l'est qui ont récupéré effectivement
l'essentiel de ces aides européennes
une fois donc c'est là où comme
malheureusement les spas details n'avait
pas anticipé que ça allait à vau qui
élabore un manque à gagner
c'est là où ils ont commencé à
s'effondrer et donc c'est là la vraie
difficulté qu'en fait c'était parce
qu'elle appelle un aléa moral
ce sont finalement les aides européennes
qui arrive donc on va continuer comme ça
maintenant un jour ça s'arrête est-ce
que dire donc c'est l'amour
on peut en vouloir je dirais à l'espagne
allait à l'époque c'est que quand elle
avait une croissance forte qui est
alimenté par la bulle immobilière les
aides européennes etc
elle aurait dû justement utiliser cette
aide pour moderniser son économie
il ya un très grand exemple que je cite
souvent c'est l'irlande l'irlande et le
portugal que en fait ces deux petits
pays qui ont la même taille à peu près
le même nombre d'habitants et qui sont
rentrés en même temps dans l'union
européenne dans les années 80 et donc à
l'époque il était en termes de pib par
habitant était dernier portugal et
l'irlande
c'était avant que la grèce arrive et
donc vingt ans plus tard même avant
l'irlande aujourd'hui avec combien en
pib par habitant elle est numéro deux
derrière luxembourg voilà donc c'est à
dire numéro 1 de luxembourg c'est quand
même un cas à part
alors que le portugal il est toujours
dans les dernières places en dehors des
pays d'europe de l'est évidemment
donc ça veut dire quoi dire qu'en fait
l'irlande a eu les mêmes aides
communautaires que le portugal mais elle
accepte ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
modernisé leurs économies ils ont baissé
les impôts ils ont fait des
investissements notamment dans tout ce
qui est numérique etc
et ça a marché ça a fait de la
croissance alors que la plupart des
autres pays tant du sud ont pris ces
aides pour faire quoi pour augmenter les
dépenses publiques et après évidemment
ça n'a pas généré une croissance future
c'est ce qui explique effectivement 7,17
différent c'est à dire que les aides
c'est bien mais ce qui compte c'est
comment on va les utiliser
et c'est là où on peut effectivement en
vouloir malheureusement à beaucoup de
vent de sud voir effectivement également
en france où on a mal utilisé et z
effectivement de l'union européenne
enfin l'irlande on a pompé en leur
collant un modèle de deux 2 pays en
franchise d'impôt on leur a collé un
modèle qui n'est pas un modèle la
franchise d'impôt c'est pas un modèle
économique où laura nous ont pas ça et
puis alors on allait dire ma oui
évidemment il ya des entreprises qui
passent par l'irlande
enfin on s'était tiré une balle dans le
pied c'est ça que ça voulait dire c'est
surtout donc c'est d'une bêtise
épouvantable ce qu'on a à faire et fièr
landes
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
cette semaine je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste président du cabinet
d'analysés économiques à ces défis
le chiffre de la semaine olivier
regarder 0 c'est le nombre de commandes
d'avions à civile que boeing a
enregistré en janvier ce n'était jamais
arrivé depuis 1962 l'interdiction de vol
du 737 max a de brillants plombe
l'entreprise et que généralement les
commandes d'avions à diminuer olivier
c'est le début de la fin drapeau boeing
en bas c'est surtout une excellente
nouvelle pour greta thomert guillemets
il ya plus d'avions non ce qui est
amusant c'est que l'on continue à nous
servir quand même une une amérique
triomphante avec une croissance
explosive et quand on regarde les
résultats des sociétés et comment vont
les principales sociétés américaines
boeing est quand même pèse lourd
ben on s'aperçoit que ça va pas si bien
que ça donc
nous induire attendant nous enduire est
on dans l'erreur
bonne nouvelle regrettez vous le disais
mais bonne nouvelle pour airbus aussi
bonne nouvelle pour airbus évidemment
alors maintenant il faut qu' il faut
qu'on en profite aussi vous savez comme
vous avez les trois quarts des
compagnies aériennes qui sont en
faillite permanente
[Rires]
ça va être compliqué donc qui est de
rentrer dans une période de récession
est dans une période difficile
économiquement qui est aussi des
annulations de commandes chez airbus ne
serait pas très étonnant
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
sachez que nos précédents numéros sont
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet
rt france point tv n'oubliez pas non
plus que vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rtk policiers le traditionnel
mot de la fin eh bien écoutez l'europe à
deux vitesses c'est une europe qui est à
la fois en marche arrière en marche
avant et c'est compliqué d'avancer